What do you attribute your longevity to and your enthusiasm too,
because you've always been a guy who loves fighting and you always been a guy
who,
I mean,
you've had that enthusiasm for a long time,
man.
You know,
not a lot of things,
uh,
can capture my attention.
You know,
like I can't just watch TV for example,
you know,
like a football game and sit through the whole thing.
You know,
I'm not trying to dis for about another,
I just don't have that attention span or basketball or baseball fighting can
just like,
I'm talking to you in a fight goes on and I'm just like almost get zoned out,
you know?
So it's always had my attention since the kids tends to be for,
I knew that I could make money off of it.
It just attracted me,
you know,
it's that primal instinct,
survival,
whatever it is,
is just hardwired deep into me,
you know?
And my longevity.
One thing I definitely attribute to his not taking steroids,
man.
Just being natural,
enjoying this ride,
the natural form,
you know,
not like pushing my body towards limits that I'm bench pressing 400 pounds when
my ligaments are weak.
Things like that,
you know.
And I also think God made me for this,
you know,
the way that I've been fighting my whole career.
You know,
I,
I have really good defense.
The last right,
it didn't show,
but I'm also like built hard man.
I walked out of the hood,
looked at,
got clipped
one left hand in the initial ft Dick kicked him,
which is crazy.
He came out,
that was the first fight I ever saw with a opening flying sidekick.
Dick kick.
Luke came to the balls.
Sorry.
Um,
but then he clipped you with was a perfect straight left,
but you survived on the ground.
You survived in the ground.
You covered up,
you showed great defense in the ground.
You got back to your feet and you kept it together.
You know,
and the combination that you hit him with,
you'd hit him with that combination a couple times.
You did.
Is that something you prepared for that when you were switching and then
throwing that left hand,
is that,
did you prepare in a way that was up on that bet?
Yeah.
Me
and my coach,
he's the one that do like all the taking the guy that had been with forever,
Paulina and nuns,
I think the greatest striking coach ever.
He,
er,
he showed me like,
Hey,
let's do this,
you know?
Oh Man,
I don't want to do on new techniques.
Come on,
let's just do it.
You know?
And then we started doing it,
doing it,
doing it.
And this was like a while ago and there's for this fight and I had stopped doing
it,
you know,
cause a lot of techniques,
we work on my lap when,
when this shooting,
when he brings me a technique to the table,
we're going to rip it out 100 times in a week and the next week the same thing
to elite fields that I got it.
And they'd be like,
all right,
cool.
It's,
it's there in the tool shed when we need it.
We'll Polish it up.
So for this fight,
he's like,
Hey,
remember that technique?
Let's,
let's bring it,
I think it'll work here.
And I go,
man,
but he's a southpaw.
He's like,
I'm telling you the way he's moving the ways you know,
fighting with you,
it's going to work.
So we started doing it and boom,
money.
You caught him with a couple of times before you put them away with it.
Right?
I not with that one,
with that same exact ones,
similar ones,
but I didn't,
uh,
I didn't go full south park to the blitz,
you know,
I did a other different ways,
and I also caught him a lot with like overhand and left hook as he was coming
in,
especially in the second one.
I caught him I think maybe twice with that come.
Yeah man,
that's a big knockout.
That was a big knockout.
He's a,
he's an interesting guy because he's really too big for one 70.
He's so fucking tall.
But you are a guy who doesn't cut much weight at all.
Like how much weight do you cut for Sec?
Whoa.
By the time I get into shape,
shape,
I'm around hundred and 82 pounds,
180 pounds.
So fight week,
I get over there and I'm like eight pounds away.
Some,
some pounds away and not so light.
Yeah,
it's nice.
I don't cut anything at 55 if,
if everything went right when he used to fight 155 I got there at 174 pounds,
173 pounds,
5% body fat,
and the rest is just water.
Man,
it would fucking kill me.
So I always felt that was too big for 55 you know,
I love the cause and competition was sifted,
but it was just getting harder and harder.
Once it took those Ibiza away,
forget it.
There was no way for me to make that weight.